Hi, I'm Ryan Sumner and I am a Chief Network Architect with IBM Cloud.
Do you know what "VPC" means?
- and why it even matters to you in your public cloud journey?
Well, today I'm going break it down.
VPC, or "Virtual Private Cloud",
is a public cloud capability
that provides you the ability to define and then control
isolated virtual networks
and then deploy cloud resources into those networks.
So, what is a virtual network?
Well, to help you understand that,
let me first help you understand
how we would deploy networks
in a standard public cloud.
An administrator is going to find a backbone,
now that backbone is going to carry all the
traffic in that cloud.
There's going to be some segmentation on that
backbone to create a separation between one
client and another client. Or let's even say
separation between one application and another
application within that same client.
So, now that we have that segmentation, we
need a network function that will actually
allow us to have communication between those
segments.
A network function we're going to call router.
So, now that we have communication between
these segments I might choose to say I don't
want traffic to flow between this segment
and that segment.
Let's say because this is customer A and this
is customer B.
So, now I have a firewall function that provides
us with filtering capabilities.
So, now I have my cloud defined, it's completely
isolated, it's not connected to the rest of
the world, but I need internet connectivity
because I'm hosting web application here.
So, now I need a network function that can
provide me with NAT-ing.
In addition, I need to extend my enterprise.
Or I have applications here that need to communicate
and get data from my enterprise on site.
So, I'm going to build a VPN function.
So, in a traditional cloud environment most
of all these network functions are actually
done with appliances. There done with appliances
that require infrastructure administrators,
or network administrators to log into them
using proprietary interface to define all
these flows and controls.
If you look at virtual networking, however
we introduce all of these capabilities as
a service. For which in case, we introduce
all these capabilities to the user where they
can now create these functions and create
this isolation and the segmentation with a
UI or CLI or API.
So, they might be able to say I want four
of these networks, and I want to find my own
custom segmentation for this application for
that application.
Now I want to have connectivity to my enterprise,
I provision a VPN service to get connectivity
to the internet instead of having to configure
NAT-ing I provided, I provision a service
to be able to be able to give me that ability.
So, now the user has this control and they
didn't need to know any proprietary interfaces
to make these connections are defined these
flows, and since each of these are networks,
they are completely isolated with each other.
They don't have connectivity between each
network until I say so.
So, let's talk about a few the benefits. Now
you understand where the virtual network comes
into play and how that actually contributes
to the private piece of V. P. C.
So, some of the benefits are because now I
can get all these all these functions and
I have isolation built in I have some security
aspects.
In addition, since these are not appliances
and actually provided has a capability of
the cloud, I can do all of this at scale.
Again, developers need things that are customizable
right. So, the aspect of being able to find
the segmentation and say I want four, five,
or six, or tear it all down and come back
tomorrow to do it again, I need some aspects
of customizing this environment.
In addition, it's flexible enough
to allow the user to be able to say I need
to be able to add virtual segmentation later
on down the road, or I need connectivity to
the enterprise down the road.
So, these two attributes here actually allow
the developers to become more agile which
hopefully is going to save you some money.
So, now you understand what virtual private
cloud is and why it matters to you.
We hope you like this video on VPC.
If you did, or have any questions, please
comment below and don't forget to like and
subscribe.